hey guys it's Justine and here with ROH
and today we are back playing some
Nintendo switch it's been a long time
since we played so much together it's
been too long and it's terrible I mean
it was probably when the switch first
came out we played like the right force
of cow udders another bottom okay yep
[Music]
it's okay my first time milk why I got
like two cups today I'm playing the new
super mario brothers u deluxe that just
came out actually we're came out a
little while ago but I haven't got a
chance to play yeah we are gonna play
through some of the little challenges so
the first one that I'm going to try to
play was booster rush okay so I don't
know I have like this yet so we'll see
how it goes
two people are playing Mario Luigi yeah
you could be me I guess so okay I'll be
Mario okay okay
no hat easy please do
I've been like a lot of my oh my gosh
okay but nah this is like I haven't done
this for years
this is been here since I played yeah
Wow what do these do what it needs to oh
I miss Carol I miss girl I'm a scared so
think be more fun
speed up speed up we're doing slow me
down slow
we just gotta blow your head up and it's
super fast as we go through the level
it's real faster yeah we got a stir
speed runs
okay it's okay it's okay I'm still alive
I started watching me behind ya there's
no time for that oh this is so
incredible you know all the guys are
still alive why not happen the liquid oh
when it's like not or not very slow guys
okay here we go here we go here we go
max speed max oh this is stressful
this yeah I like the speedruns tho cuz
it's okay forces you you have to keep
going that was fun to retailer Best
Breakthrough yeah this is what I like
about it is that if you start you can
always in battle so basically this will
pick it for you yeah yes yeah you can
because this is battle like we want
right now if you're winning I didn't
like that I thought I was throwing it up
this little fighting no it's okay that's
basically what you want to be doing I
thought we're throwing it up
you know okay little Luigi I didn't want
to throw it at you that's all sweet
because I really suck at this so just be
like really grasp it are you just killed
me he just knocked me out
so you're mine you take some boxing
classes girl because I feel like all
right I just walked off a door yeah I
need to do that a lot of us you and
Maureen I thought it was you see that's
the problem that we've been having
we're to suppose we keep switching we
keep switching we know and then I think
it's okay that's fine okay so then it
isn't why are we surprised okay this
wire actually you would have beat me cuz
you collected more boy this problem
because what I was like human Mario okay
okay get away get the coins alright go
just take it go hit the coins keep the
coins okay I'm green I'm green whoa
you're great I'm Rio you are green girl
you are you are I'm Mario need to go
okay I'm Luigi
I don't Luigi I am little Luigi I am
Luigi Oh
I'm having so watch this all day like
playing music we playing these maps
again
chase you do things face again are they
smart do they have a travel course I
think that he may have a travel course
no he's heard of it we just trying to
get me to him Americans are upsides are
dead or I'm dead the design is fine yeah
look at all these quit so many points
it's a huge creepy dragon eel I mean how
is that fair see I only played together
not against each other it's harder this
is like competitive and I don't like
being competitive I already have our at
enough time as it is so if it's not like
a teamwork situation yeah I'm just like
I might not be enough floating over the
entire game well at least this is
cumulative so as we keep playing like
you could potentially win that's wrong
oh my goodness okay god it's just a life
lesson different still to never give up
don't you ever give up on yourself
because if you keep jumping you live
it's true Oh
I think like maybe you're dreaming and
you did magic oh they have Peter do I'm
just like I'm just wanted I'm just
wanted because see here's my thought is
like I already collected some of the
little hats I really like the blue I did
too it's super cute
anything outfit so that was the final
round I love the coy brush that's
pulling I think there's so much times
just like get better you just have like
a game area with an actual game night
not recording just can we do it can
easily show you some better gaming setup
to me I'll get us both a nice set up
it'll be incredible
I'll bring some snacks you find it you
have to gain down what are these oh I
think it's only for one player okay do
it I'll cheer you on
I'll be over here your leaders try it
okay yes yes I'm attacking so basically
speed runs oh okay let's do it
yeah okay to reach it in 53 seconds or
less to get gold there we go
like I'm pretty good at you're gonna go
too fast what you cruel is you are
really fast but I'm not oh man this is
gonna be so addicting yeah I'll put you
back alright I get real feisty see I
always feel like those are close balls
cuz I feel you lay on his head well I
think she was like wasn't high enough
is that why now I know but I just
thought that I would be able to jump
over it
they're so cute Christina I don't know
if he knows that we actually made the
boxes that look like little goombas
that's so cute yeah they were delicious
I think they really root beer-flavored
it was a while back I'm like a nerdy
nummies yeah you're delicious and they
look just like goombas that is so cute
so I feel like look at you fly you fly
girl I mean I actually had a little that
ride hurt that hurt there's two there's
two there's two that hurt me oh my
goodness I'm not gonna I'm not gonna get
it I didn't either
I didn't get it I got silver what do you
want gold platinum you know you veneers
you want first let me I mess up one
single little thing you gotta reach it
in 40 seconds Oh last like these are so
hard
30 seconds 30 seconds for what okay go
girl go fly like those little legs I'm
gonna find the heart just fly just
cruise on top of all of these don't even
care about 900 that got you but hurt you
can do it you can do it you could do it
you one more one more one more that we
got this this is so fun this is like
Olympics it has bronze silver and then
gold just like the medals that's how
they do it makes a lot of sense Cocoplum
I'm shoot as a little slow but you know
what fine fine fine we can get it badly
I don't think we can yes yes yes yes yes
yes that's that's so hard and broad
that's a medal will take it it's a metal
we'll take it take it you're still me
Olympics who cares I feel like this
might be my new addiction his ploy nice
well things are playing this with me you
are very welcome and I'm proud of you
look these medals
this is incredible wiving for the next
videos we should probably try to play
through the actual game so that would be
really fun do you wanna be really fun to
have a scare but I love it so you
shouldn't be scared it
okay okay okay cool guys thank you so
much for watching go check out burrows
Channel we have some fun videos coming
out very shortly for you guys do you
guys want to see more gaming stuff yes
please said yes okay you guys let's just
put it out there I know my stuff get
gaming okay it's all out there cards on
the table I'm not hiding anything but I
love it so you have so much fun and I
love gaming with us it's so fun and she
teaches me things so I'll get better
over time we will both progress I'll
start at the dirt level and we'll move
up to bronze and silver and all those
other things we should definitely play
Mario Kart one day cuz the hell are you
I'm not good okay at that I'm mediocre
at that okay it's great that's it I'll
see you guys later
[Music]